Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Hank, you just got said hello to by the members of the support group from The Fault in Our Stars movie.
I've been on set for the movie for the last couple weeks, and very little news, like, penetrates the bubble of the movie,
so I want to thank you for your video about the government shutdown, which I previously didn't understand at all,
and now understand only in the sense that I'm, like, "Are you serious, that... really?'
Anyway, great video. So, earlier this week, I got to ask Ansel Elgort, who plays Augustus Waters in the movie,
some real questions from real Nerdfighters.
[J:] You ready? Hold on, I gotta use my thumbprint... 'cause I got my fancy new phone
[A:] Whoahh [J:] What what what? [A:] Is this the 5S? [J:] It is, don't touch, don't touch, it's not for regular people, just for specials.
"What's it like working with a brilliant author like John Green?"
[A:] Um, y'know what, I thought it would be better. I was expecting much more.
[J:] There's a lot of people asking if what they call 'Johnsel' is gonna be a thing.
[A:] Yeah, I think it's already a thing.
[J:] I think It's a thing. It's a thing. I ship it. [A:] Me too. [J:] Yeah. Um. My wife, who's here on set, was like, 'on Twitter you're acting like you have a crush on Ansel'
And I was like- [A:] "cause I do. [J:] ACTING?
"What was you favorite scene to film in the movie so far?" [A:] Friday night, we did the scene in the car, where Gus... [J:] You don't have to say it no spoilers!
That's perfect. I think people will know that that refers to, but people who haven't read the book won't be spoiled, that perfect.
That was your favorite? [A:] Yeah, it was pretty - that was, I think that's actually my favorite scene I've ever done as an actor.
[J:] So tell me the story of how you found out that you'd gotten the part. [A:] I was in Chicago and I was shooting Divergent. And, on Divergent,
me and Shai had become friends, and I was going to New York City for the weekend.
She gave me a package. Said, 'do not open this package, whatever you do.' And I said 'why not?'
She said 'just don't open it.' I get on the airplane, everything, whatever. Go home, 4 days pass.
Still can't open the package. Then I get a call from Josh Boone. He says, 'hey Ansel, did Shailene give you a package?'
And I say, 'yeah!' He said, 'open up the package.' So I open up the package, it was like really hard to open,
it was just covered in tape, it was a very secure package. And inside was a rotten Dutch cheese and tomato sandwich.
And he said, 'we're going to Amsterdam!' And that's how I knew I got the part.
[J:] Oh my goodness, is that not the cutest thing you've ever heard? Also, while on, set I got to interview Mike Birbiglia,
one of my favorite comedians/people, who plays Patrick in the movie.
[M:] What attracted me to the movie was... [J:] The book. [M:] Originally, [J:] It was the book. [M:] Well, [J:] It was the book.
[M:] I'll tell you the exact sequence of events, and then we can make up... [J:] Sure. [M:] the version for this.
[J:] Basically, Burbiglia loved The Spectacular Now, became friends with the screenwriters,
who recommended The Fault in Our Stars, what-whatever, the story we made up is much better.
[M:] Here's a version of the story that might be better for television. Uhm, [J:] You read the book. [M:] I read the book.
[Talking on top of each other] [M:] I wrote, [J:] It was so , it was so special to you, [M:] It was so special to me,
[J:] You wrote me an e- [M:] I wrote you a letter, [J:] A letter, letter. It was a letter. [M:] It was a letter.
[J:] A letter. [M:] And it was a long thing, like in the middle ages. [Together:] It was on a scroll.
[J:] Exactly. [M:] And you said, "what is this weird scroll? [J:] It's so strange. But,
[M:] That somebody sent me?" [J:] But, I saw this guy's movie, [M:] Yeah. [J:] and he's pretty funny,
[M:] Right. [J:] And, um, he should play Augustus.
[M:] Yes. [J:] And them, um,
[M:] Yeah, that's the obvious choice [J:] The studio was like, 'he's a little old.' [M:] Mm-mm.
Yeah. [J:] Yeah, so then we were like, [M:] Though I'm not! [J:] No, yeah, you're not [M:] That's what they said.
[J:] Of course you're not. That's, they were wrong [M:] Yeah, yeah. [J:] Studios!
Ah, now, it's so- it's so sweet. Uhm... We're not supposed to look directly at the camera.
[M:] That was going terribly. [J:] Yeah, that was one of the worst hugs I've ever had in my life, oh god.
[M:] You didn't prompt me that you were gonna go for that hug. [J:] Well I was- I was... It's good, yeah.
Good, good interview. Hank, clearly I missed my calling, I should've been a professional interviewer.
Anyway, I'll see you on Friday. No, it is Friday! I'll see you on Tuesday. What? I- why did we switch up,
it's making everything weird. If the government hadn't shut down, none of this would've happened.
It would've been me Tuesday, Hank Friday, Me Tue- now, who even knows anymore. I'll see you at some indeterminate point in the future. Thanks, government.